huge in that first half for Los Angeles
28 points and Austin Reeves joins us now
here at the table congratulations on
winning the first ever NBA cup I I got
to ask you what was going on in your
mind in that first half because you had
22 points that's the most you've ever
scored in one half in your career uh I
thought I was just playing the game the
right way obviously when you got guys
like Bron and AD and DLo on the court
you know it makes it easy you know for
you but um you know that's one thing I
try to pride myself on is playing the
game the right way and I just um you
know tried to you know be a aggressive
yeah I think you talk about the word
aggressive um I watched it you play it
the right way but it seemed like you
surveyed this game and when you came in
it was Ultra aggressive for you getting
downhill attacking absorbing contact and
just playing with a mindset I'm playing
with Force yeah I mean uh like I said
just being aggressive and trying to get
to the rim and free throw line uh you
know they're not the best paint you know
defensive team so you know it was a
focus for us going into the game um to
get you know in there and try to operate
around the room what was the game plan
for Tyrese halber he's been incredible
you obviously done very well through
Team USA but what was the game plan
going in because that first half you
guys did a really good job on it yeah I
mean it's it's hard anytime you got to
guard somebody uh that unselfish that
talented and plays the game the right
way as well uh we just wanted to make it
tough for him uh we wanted to you know
kind of cut off their Outlets uh cuz
they like to play with such Pace um but
like I said at the end of the day it's
almost impossible to you know really
control a guy like that uh you can just
try to make it as hard as you can you
know Austin we got a chance to watch
this performance but that's your
teammate Anthony Davis what did you see
out from Anthony Davis what was just a
little bit different we all know he has
that talent but it was just a a
different Focus for ad tonight yeah I
mean when ad plays like that ' 80s you
know arguably the best player in the NBA
and you know you could just see as
aggressive on the offensive glass uh you
know getting wedge rebounds being able
to you know get easy putbacks and then
just I you know I've said it many a
times his defense is uh Second To None
the way he basically Staples our defense
on that end um like I said it's second
to none and tonight he just you know
brought all that to the you know table
and uh played a really good basketball
game it's funny LeBron mentioned this
again today he said hey this is great
this is amazing to win this thing but
it's still December there's still steps
to be made before we get to April but it
didn't feel like LeBron was playing in
December I I mean especially these last
few games defensively ratch it up just
go through the process of seeing him
play that way yeah I mean anytime you
know your two best players ad and Bron
play like that uh you know it has a
trickle down effect and you know you can
see it in the New Orleans game when he
took three charges in the first half uh
first one on Zion and just his uh you
know mental you know lock down on you
know all the details which you know it's
always like that but you could tell is a
little bit more you know he really
wanted to win this and uh you know get
another uh you know trophy on the Shelf
well Austin looking look at you guys and
running through stats everything was
paint paint paint but to be able to win
this game with only making two threes
you know that's huge for you guys yeah I
mean I didn't know that until I I
literally looked at it when I sit down
which is crazy uh you know you won't you
see many games you know in the NBA W by
only making two threes or honestly less
than five threes um but like I said you
know with the way ad and Brian played
downhill and you know love to attack the
paint um you know we can put so much
pressure on defenses to get to the free
throw line and um really just control
the game that way well congratulations
uh I know it's a big night in La get the
NBA cup also getting show Otani but the
dodg is not too bad either unless you're
a Canadian like me then it sucks cuz I
thought he was going to Toronto anyways
congratulations a for sure appreciate
y'all